today we saw a stark contrast play out
before our eyes in real-time the
contrast of two leaders Nancy Pelosi and
Donald Trump now Pelosi is a leader in
title only
yeah she's the Speaker of the House but
I think I'm right last spring she said
impeachment should only be bipartisan
the same speaker who couldn't get one
Republican to join her lynch mob but
that didn't stop her today from milking
the conveyance of the articles of
impeachment for all it was worth
house of representatives impeached the
President of the United States an
impeachment that will last forever this
is a very serious matter and we take it
to heart and it really solemn way
impeachment Oh that's why she was
wearing peach I couldn't figure the
color out today it was a day of
choreographed moments though that were
supposed to indicate the seriousness the
prayerfulness of all of this not
political at all of course but it only
underscored the vacuous nosov Pelosi and
her collaborators we are here today to
cross a very important threshold in
American history today we will make
history the threshold in history as we
make that history we were making
progress for the American people
put it miss Smithsonian well actually
how is a sham impeachment was zero
convincing charges at all making
progress for the American people it's
not there was one person making progress
for the American people today it was
Donald Trump while Nancy was trying to
pass herself off as a second Betsy Ross
Trump was signing phase one of a trade
pact with China that will directly
benefit you the American workers and our
industry now this is a deal no one
thought was going to happen but it
tackles intellectual property theft has
real enforcement triggers still keeps
tariffs in place to keep the Chinese
honest we're going to work together for
the benefit of our countries but also
very importantly for the benefit of the
world so this is a very big day for the
United States sorry mr. president but
Pelosi was not going to be bested by
some historic trade deal now she had her
own signing ceremony of the articles of
impeachment platters of
hors d'oeuvres that were I guess Lee I
guess pins were brought out to
commemorate the occasion which she
clumsily used to create her signature so
solemn that all the co-conspirators were
given a booby prize Maxine Waters looked
like she was waiting for the Rolling
Stones to show up it's not a magic wand
auntie maximexi I can't get through this
but don't worry
Nancy quickly restored order and the
appropriate net solemnity when they
bring this over will set in motion a
process on the Senate side they will
take a special oath of office to do
impartial judges and do impartial
justice according to the Constitution
and the laws justice judges it happens
to the best of us Nancy honestly
especially late at night this is a total
joke next came a solemn procession of
the Articles to the upper chamber it was
like a parade of fools getting there
steps in for the day
the only thing that the parade lacked
was Nancy in the lead carrying the
patriotic incense or maybe twirling a
baton years from now when we look back
on this day no one's gonna remember
Nancy's cheap theatrics they will
remember though how President Trump
brought the Chinese to the bargaining
table and delivered achievements few
ever thought were possible this is what
real leadership looks like and only one
of those signing pens will be worth a
damn a year from now and that's the
angle